Okay y'all, important question: If I kiss
a frog do I get a princess or do I get warts?
Asking for
a friend.
This week's Viewer Question comes from Caitlin
Willix-Payne who wants to know: How / Why
do warts form?
Chances are, you've heard people says "I love
my friend, warts and all!"
A wart on the chin is the devil within!
Warts get a bad rap.
They're associated with frogs and witches
and thought to be begat from having a mean
disposition, washing hands in water where
eggs were boiled, slaughtering a frog, or
being a solitary young woman (victorian-speak
for a lady who masturbates).
Regardless, warts have been viewed as an affliction
throughout history, writings in ancient Greek,
Roman and Egyptian texts all make references
to warts and their varying types; possible
causes and cures…
But early 19th century scientists were the
first to explore their contagious nature,
and possible medical cures.
Warts are the second most common skin problem
humans face.
Acne is number one.
Warts can occur anywhere on the skin, but
commonly show up on hands, feet and faces;
and if you think about what's causing them,
that's by design!
Warts are caused by the human papilloma virus
-- that's right HPV.
HPV is usually the name given to the sexually
transmitted infection; because they're the
same TYPE of virus, but you're not getting
genital warts on your face, trust me.
The human papilloma virus has over 100 different
strains, and only some of them cause warts
on the genitals; the strain can determine
which warts you'll have, but since everyone's
immune system is different some people won't
get warts at all; it's more common in kids
and old people.
There are six different wart types.
Common warts -- verruca vulgaris -- are roundish,
firm, and might look like a cauliflower; they're
usually on fingers or knees.
Verrucas -- plantar warts -- are white, flat
and form on the soles of the feet.
I had one of these, that was the day I learned
doctors can "burn" things off you with dry
ice.
Ouch.
Filiform warts -- verruca filiformis -- are
slender and show up on the neck, face, eyelids
and armpits.
Periungual -- show up under the fingernails
or toenails and are shaped like the nail;
and Mosaic warts and Plane warts (verruca
plana) will form in clusters that are either
flat or look like mosaic tiles on the face,
hands, foot soles and legs,.
Normally warts will come and go; they're the
result of the HPV virus trying to spread,
because it spreads by skin-to-skin contact.
Generally, you can't just "catch" warts casually,
but it's possible.
Wet or scraped skin will increase the chances
of spreading the virus; but you CAN get it
from touching someone's towel, exercise equipment,
or walking barefoot where someone with the
virus has walked.
If you HAVE a wart, scratching, biting, shaving,
or sucking on it can spread the virus around,
so don't do that.
Because it's a virus, there's no cure, so
once you have it, you just… have it; but
let's not fearmonger here… it's mostly nothing.
Plus, though the virus isn't curable, the
warts are.
Remedies are available at most pharmacies,
but if you're feeling ambitious, you can use
dry ice or duct tape -- look online for how.
No joke, wrapping a wart in duct tape for
six days and then pumicing will remove a wart.
It's weird, but it works.
In the end, the HPV virus that causes warts
probably already exists inside of you.
6.2 million new HPV cases are reported every
year according to the CDC, and by age 50 -- 80
percent of women will have it.
It's real common.
Vaccines exist to stop the dangerous strains;
so go get that if you ARE worried and you'll
be all safe
and stuff.